depuis par exemple 2005 c'est à dire
quand le peuple s'est prononcé contre le
traité européen et qui eut un référendum
qui a clairement fait savoir que la pop
ne voulait pas de ce référendum et on a
vu la classe politique dans sa
quasi-totalité considéré que ce que le
peuple n'avait pas voulu
eh bien il aurait tout de même avec le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale c'est à
dire le congrès et je pense qu'il ya eu
là un genre de coup d'état qui a fait
que nous entrions en ce moment là dans
une ère qui n'était plus une ère
démocratique nous sommes dans une ère
post démocratique on pourrait ajouter
effectivement que nombre d'intellectuels
gênant ce fonds se font les uns c'est
moi j'ai été par exemple mis à la porte
de france culture ce que je gêne et
emmanuel macron nombre de journaux qui
sont subventionnées par l'argent public
la tienne un discours idéologique dans
lequel il dément n'y a pas beaucoup de
place pour la liberté l'intelligence on
insulte beaucoup les gens qui ne sont
pas dans la logique libérale de
maastricht les gens qui sont aujourd'hui
employées dans les médias français je
pense à france inter par exemple sont
des médias d'état ou arte sont des
médias qui sont qui fonctionne avec
l'argent public sont des médias
totalement idéologique dans lesquelles
la liberté est inexistante c'est à dire
que quand on parle de gens qui ne
pensent pas comme com com comme ces gens
pensent et bien on est considéré comme
un nazi un fachiste appétit nist avec
mon ami stéphane simon nous avons lancé
une revue souverainiste cette revue
n'existait pas encore que dans un grand
nombre de journaux nous étions déjà
traité de fasciste de pétainiste j'ai
moi-même été assimilée à jacques doriot
par bernard henri lévy dans le point de
radio ce bien quelqu'un qui a créé un
parti fasciste en france et qui a porté
l'uniforme nazi sur le front russe et la
liberté n'existe plus depuis bien
longtemps en france depuis effectivement
au moins une dizaine 1992 je dirais que
depuis que nous sommes entrés dans l'ère
maastricht yens
la souveraineté française a disparu nous
n'obéissons plus qu'au capital qu'à
l'argent et au marché et je suis bien
heureux que le comique permettent aux
gens de s'en rendre compte ça fait bien
longtemps que je parle tout seul dans le
désert est presque dans le vide et la
légende et cours effectivement que les
libertés sont en péril mais ça fait bien
longtemps que
la radio la télévision l'école
l'université les grands médias et la
classe politique dans son ensemble sont
très sains ce sujet de la démocratie